I'm Curtin Divina reading for reviewer
Steve Watts minecraft represented a
massive paradigm shift in games having
served as a popular proto example of
both early access release and
unstructured creation based gameplay
more than a decade later minecraft
dungeons doesn't strive toward
revolutionary but it may just use the
now-familiar trappings of its namesake
to introduce a new generation of players
to old-school tropes the dungeon crawler
is a light breezy introduction to the
genre for newcomers and a friendly
low-impact callback for veterans those
experience with games like Diablo or
torchlight already know the basic gist
you venture from a hub area into various
environments battle enemy hordes
occasionally fell some larger-than-life
boss monsters and then spend time laying
out and sorting through your new loot
like a kid will just open a pack of
baseball cards within that framework
there is some simplification in
Minecraft dungeons which helps to make
it more inviting you only have six gear
slots melee bow armor and three artifact
based abilities you won't find
specialized classes or complex skill
trees here everything is tied to your
armor sets and the level ups mostly
matter and that they determine the
quality of your loot drops that loot
rains down constantly
sometimes a sprinkle but more often a
monsoon which means you'll be constantly
swapping your weapons and armor sets
minecraft dungeons is far more precious
with its gear so it's not uncommon to
find yourself switching three or four
times in a single stage at first these
upgrades appear pretty linear replacing
a sword with a new stronger sword but
before long the enchantment system comes
into play which provides dungeons with
its strategic depth enchantments are
specialized upgrades to each of your
primary pieces of gear each level of
gives you an enchantment point to select
one from a handful passive buffs but you
earn back your spent points whenever you
salvage a piece of equipment that's
already been enchanted in the early game
when a weapon might only have one
enchantment slot and fairly vanilla
buffs
these are nice bonuses but don't
significantly impact how you approach
the game as you progress later these
instrumental and adding depth in a
difficulty ramp finding more complex
enchantment combinations can make the
difference between a brittle build or a
powerhouse that also makes the search
for new loot both thrilling and
progressively more thoughtful since you
earn your in Chapman points back for
salvaging swapping out a new piece of
gear means you can enchant it with
several upgrades from the start the late
game is a series of constant trade-offs
finding your rhythm with a new set of
abilities and buffs before exchanging
them for something completely different
while enchantments make of the combat
strategically complex
the moment-to-moment gameplay is
relatively simple most melee attacks
don't stagger opponents so there's no
weight or impact hits you'll often just
hit enemies as they hit you like a
couple of Rock'em Sock'em robots until
one of you falls down the melee weapons
are well differentiated by their tech
speed and range but that's basically all
melee battle can also feel a little
unfair when you're surrounded by mobs
and unable to move especially if you
find yourself dropped there by surprise
from a jump pad sometimes the simplicity
of the combat can get in its own way you
can pick up TNT boxes as random drops
and carry them around with you for when
you need a quick area of effect attack
but the throw command is set to the same
button as the ranged attack that makes
it impossible to fire an arrow without
getting rid of the TNT boxes you may
have been saving and the two don't
really serve the same function this just
means you have to sacrifice your a OE
availability any time you need the
precision of an arrow or anytime you
forget in the heat of the moment which
happened to me more times than I can
count
minecraft dungeons is short on its
default difficulty setting completing
default opens up adventure mode with
higher-level enemies in better loot and
completing adventure opens apocalypse
the game is built around relatively
short self-contained repeatable stages
each with difficulty sliders adventure
mode starts to roll out gear with more
powerful abilities that both provides
more incentive to keep hunting better
loot on the higher difficulty and gives
you something to do with excess and
chapman points this emphasis on finding
Luke comes at the expense of the in-game
economy because despite finding gems
frequently throughout dungeons there
just isn't much use for them
you can spend them to roll
piece of gear your camp but it hardly
ever stacks up to the gear you've
already found and turning unwanted gear
to salvage only gets you a fraction of
your money back as a result it's not
really worth it and there's nothing else
to spend your hard-won gems on the
stages themselves are minecraft accurate
carrying over an aesthetic made of parts
that are clearly recognizable to anyone
who has spent time in the block building
game the minecraft spirit is also
carried through mobs themselves classic
enemies like creepers or skeletons are
among the first you'll see and sometimes
the stage will darken for randomized
visit from the Enderman as a mini-boss
encounter dungeons also find ways to
create its own bits of Minecraft
identity like the addition of the
adorable key golem the co-op works
without a hitch offering an easy way to
join up with friends or guide less
experienced players through tough
challenges gear can be concentrated in
different directions with emphasis on
elements like healing or damage
mitigation which could theoretically
allow a very well-coordinated team
replicate the standard tank healer DPS
model realistically though a team will
be compromised of several single-player
builds and simply having partners work
to help mitigate some of the crowd
control issues that exist when going
solo a few smart inclusions like
color-coded loot and quick teleport tool
make it simple to stay together and let
everyone enjoy their winnings it is odd
though that starting an offline game
still functions like a connected one
including the inability to pause
minecraft dungeons is missing
conspicuous parts of what gave the
namesake its identity most noticeably
breaking through walls to explore
underground caverns and using the found
materials to craft but maybe because of
that dungeons shows how flexible the
franchise has become rather than shift
our expectations of what games can be
it's baking on its own popularity to
introduce players to a classic genre
they might not have tried before and
serve as a short but sweet treat for
looter vets
[Music]
you